[Musik]
man darf dich nikulin nicht uns sondern
man muss sie auf den kopf stellen warten
bis der schnee zusammen kommt und dann
umdrehen und anständig erwähnt erzählt
der dritte kennt alle geheimnisse rund
um die schneekugel in dieser werkstatt
in wien hat schon sein großvater erwin
pertschy der erste experimentiert er war
mechaniker für chirurgie instrumente und
erfinder mit einer glaskugel voll wasser
wollte er eigentlich das nicht für den
operationssaal verstärken
mein großvater hat vor 121 jahren
genauer durch reinen zufall die
schneekugel erfunden
er hat in der küche von seiner mutter
gries gefunden hat den griese und dieses
wasser hinein gegeben und der gries hat
sich mit wasser geworfen und es so ganz
langsam zu boden geschwebt und wird das
gesehen hat hat sich gedachte sieht aus
also sind dieser kugel schnell und das
war die basis idee für disney co in der
werkstatt fand sein großvater zudem eine
miniatur der österreichischen
wallfahrtskirche maria zell mit schuh
passte bemalte er einen sockel und
klebte die kirche in die mitte der
glaskugel im jahr 1900 ließ er sich die
erste schneekugel der welt patentieren
mit der wiener rezeptur rieseln die
flocken besonders sanft erst mein vater
hat dann die mischung hergestellt vom
schnee die wir heute noch verwenden und
das ist mein persönliches geheimnis dass
wir es momentan ruhig
rund 200.000 kugeln werden jedes jahr in
der wiener manufaktur hergestellt
fast alle einzelteile stammen aus
lokaler produktion
die figuren werden in handarbeit
gefertigt dazu wird flüssiger kunststoff
in metall formen gegossen und gepresst
seit vergangenem jahr arbeitet familie
per sie zusätzlich mit 3d druck diese
daten werden dann an den drucker
geschickt und der drucker produziert
dann schicht für schicht die figur
pinguine tochter sabine herze die zweite
führt seit kurzem den betrieb in vierter
generation weiter als erste frau in der
familiengeschichte die zukunft des
unternehmens sieht sie positiv tradition
ist bei den kunden beliebt zurück zum
ursprung man will wissen was man
konsumiert wo die sachen herkommen die
man kauft bei einer jeden schneekugel
die dieses haus hall es lässt sich
zurückverfolgen wer hat s produziert
diese kugel hat ein gesicht und das sind
wir das ist meine familie
auch erwin platzes ehefrau bemalt
täglich mehrere dutzend kugeln viele
kunden geben motive in auftrag um
gegenüber nachahmen und
billigproduzenten bestehen zu können
setzt die familie auf originalität und
beweist bei der umsetzung humor auch in
der korona krise
[Musik]
also das ist die berühmteste schneekugel
vom jahr 2020 unsere schneekugel mit dem
toilettenpapier war der verkaufsschlager
die leute sind auf der gasse das nicht
schlange gestanden um so eine
schneekugel zu bekommen
direkt neben der werkstatt befindet sich
das familieneigene schneekugel museum
die wiener schneekugel ist ein wahrer
exportschlager sogar drei ehemalige us
präsidenten haben ein exklusives
exemplar im regal stehen
so wie etwa diese kugel der familie
obama ein gastgeschenk einer wienerin
für das weiße haus
mehr als 350 motive gehören mittlerweile
zum sortiment
wenn man da rein schaut ist das eine
richtig schöne heile welt das ist meine
welt seit mehr als 40 jahren und mit
sicherheit der schneesicherste ort
österreichs